Dear LeBron
I'm sorry this had to happen this way
That I didn't tell you sooner
Claiming the O'Brien Throne with you
was one of the proudest moments of my life
And I will be forever grateful for the lessons you've taught me
But I can no longer fight in your shadow
Sure, we had our differences
But the real problem
is that we're very much the same
Many men succumb to the allure of rings and superteams
only to obscure a deeper desire
to be The Man
While this chapter comes to a close
a new door is opened
beyond which lies the knowledge of my true potential
I may find that I was mistaken
That I needed you all along
Or maybe I'll discover
that I am more powerful than I ever dreamed
And so I've set sail for the edge of the world
But if I find that this world is indeed round
then maybe one day
my journey will lead me back to you
In my stead awaits another
You may recall his words from last year
Well, his wish has been granted
There will be...
A new...
King in the East
King James is late to his own meeting
Doesn’t bode well for us getting out of this slump
Hopefully he’s finalizing a trade for Kevin
Am I right?
Freakin' Kevin
What is that?
That's odd
Some sort of pregnant raven
Oh no...
WOJ BOMB!! OH SH-
Bring out your busts!
We'll take your whiffed draft picks and bloated contracts
We’ll pay heaps of gold on the back end for your mediocre youngsters
Bugger off, poacher!
Bring out your busts!
Here, you can have him after all
Hey, there he is! The Knight of Crabbes
You should've been here all along, eh?
Here you go, for your troubles
Ew. Gross!
All right, off we go, Allan!
Welcome home
Bring out your busts!
We'll take your busts for a small fee!
Ah, Ser Lowry, I’d love to see you in a Nets tunic
Not me. Him
Ah...the horse who does horse things?
No. The–the guy on the horse
Ah, Ser DeMarre Carroll!
Oh boy, that contract's a doozy
'Fraid I’m gonna need a couple draft picks to take him on!
Ugh fine, but just keep this between us
I know, I know, I get it
Lord Ujiri got an unblemished record. Blah blah blah blah blah
On you go
Bring out your busts, your bloated contracts!
Ah! Bryan Long Collars!
Two for me, eh? Sauce Castillo and Ser Okafor. Very nice
Wait. I'm not a bust
He says he's not a bust
Oh, he's a bust all right
So you’re just gonna send me off to Brooklyn. Just like that?
Yes. It’ll be a fresh start
Right, well why not Bostonia?
Look, Jahlil, I’ve tried…everywhere
Well that’s cause...I’ve just been in a...bad situation
You couldn't even beat out Richaun Holmes!
Well maybe if I had some veteran leadership, or some archers to space the field
He’s got a point there
I roll out of bed and get 20 and 10s
The only thing you get out bed for is a cheesesteak
That’s not true. I'm vegan now. I’m in the best shape of me life
See? Look at me, I’m vegan Jah!
Look! I’m getting back on defense! Look at my defensive effort!
Look, can you please take this guy, the scribes are killing me
I'll throw in a second-rounder.  I’ll take anything in return
Hmm…how about this guy?
Huh, what? What?
He's good on D and has 18 businesses
Uh...
[Dry heaves]
Vegan Jah
Ugh. You know what? Fine. Deal. Done
Alright, enjoy Trevor Booker!
Bring out your busts!
We’ll take your whiffed draft picks and bloated contracts!
Stick stance, Nicholas
OK, sorry
Going off his numbers from last year,
you could make the case he’s become one of the best shooters in the Realm
[Scoff]
You can never have too much shooting, Steph
Klay, your thoughts?
Huh? Um
Yeah. Um.
Yeah, I think it’s unsafe. A bit shaky
I think Swaggy P could be an asset
Lord Commander! Lord Commander!
Yes, Patrick?
A raven…just came in...Woj–er, Shams...Bomb
House Hornets has traded for...Dwight Howard
Hm, good for them. Nothing to concern ourselves with
Thank you, Patrick. Let us know if you hear of anything else
Aye, Lord Commander
Swaggy has his moments, but all too often plays the fool
They said the same of JaVale, but I’d say he’s worked out quite nicely
Aye
I just...I worry how many of these jester types can we absorb until...
Lord Commander! L-Lord Commander!
Yes, Patrick?
Another raven. He’s crossed the Narrow Sea!
Who?
Furkan...Furkan Korkmaz
Oh, ugh, Patrick...
They-they say he might make the Sixers active roster.
They-they say he might make the Sixers' active roster.
Oh, ugh. OK, Patrick. Um. Maybe just notify us if any...big
names change Houses. Understood?
Right, right. Big names. Got it.
I, for one, think Nick’s presence will help
He’s one of the best catch-and-shoot guys out there
Aye, and Lord Walton speaks well of his defense
I mean, I like the lad, it’s just I’m concerned
Lord Commander! Another raven!
Sorry to interrupt, but-but it’s a big name. Hall of Famer!
OK
Vince Carter
He’s joining...House Kings!
We’re not worried about House Kings, Patrick
Come on, Patrick
But...but you said big names and he’s—
He’s bloody 40 years old, Patrick!
I, I don't know.  I, I just...get a bad feeling about him
Here, how about this: Only inform us of anything that actually matters to a house of our stature
So say, one of the Great Houses of the West makes a move that directly affects us
That sort of thing
Right. Something that hurts our chances?
Right
Got it
If you think it’s a good fit. That he’ll know his role
You may be right. This is not the Swaggy P of yore
He’s known as Uncle Swaggy now
Alright, so it is agreed
He’ll be examined by the maesters on the morrow,
and if they deem him fit, then a contract shall be
Ugh, he’s coming. He's coming up. He’s coming back up
Lord, Lord Commander!
Ah here he comes
Lord Commander! I’ve got major news! Multiple ravens!
This better be good
Yes! Ser Chris Paul has been traded to House Rockets
But wait, there’s more!
Jimmy Butler is joining Karl-Anthony and the Maple Knight in Minnesota!
And there’s more, it’s worse
Paul George and Carmelo Anthony will be joining The Brodie on House Thunder
That’s three new Super Houses. All in the West
Again, Patrick? Please
Only bring us news that actually affects our chances
When will Lord Sarver and your master of basketball operations be arriving?
They have entrusted me as emissary. Now what is this trade?
Trade? No
We’ve come to discuss an alliance
An alliance?
How would that even work?
Think of it more as a merger
Individually, our houses are weak
but together, we can dominate the West as House Kings Suns!
[Triumphant Horn]
Eh...don’t love it
But hold on. But what if I told you you
could play alongside the next Steph Curry?
[Laughter]
Right. It’s just the name “Kings Suns.” It’s awkward
What about Sun Kings?
OK fine, from here on we are House Sun Kings, OK?
We are the Sun Kings
[Triumphant Horn]
We’ve taken the liberty of drafting a standard for our new combined house
Buddy!
Flip it one more
I can’t really see the sun
What do y--It’s in the front of the crown!
Uh, excuse me
I was thinking maybe…I was thinking maybe a crown inside a sun?
Ooh like a fiery crown. I like that.
Thanks yeah, I like to paint so…I think about like compositions and stuff
I think it’s great. We want that. The flaming crown
Oh come on! Buddy and Bogdan spent like three practices stitching this together!
It’s fine, it’s fine, my lord.
It is a small price to pay for a dragon
Dragon?
Yes.  Everyone is actually quite keen to have a look
You mean Dragan?
Huh?
I mean, here he is
That’s a bit of a shit dragon
Where’s its wings?
And scales?!
I’m still developing you guys, come on
Oh I see, so the dragon is actually a person
Great job researching, Vlade, really good researching there
I didn’t realize–I just read the notes the scouts gave me, they said dragon
Did you draft De'Aaron Fox because you thought he was a fox?
Foxes are smart
Ugh God. It’s fine, it’s fine
We can evaluate all our assets when we join forces in Sacramento!
You mean in Phoenicia
Oh for heaven sakes! We just built a state-of-the-art castle
Isn’t Sacramento a bit small?
You want us to go to Phoenicia when It’s a hundred
and f--king twenty degrees every day?!
It gets cool at night
And besides, do you expect us to abandon a city with such a rich basketball history?
Well clearly you are not familiar with the rich history of House Kings
Lord Commander Adelman and his
Adelman
...corner offense?
Oh come on, they don’t even compare to D’Antoni’s Seven Seconds or Less offense!
What are you talking? We had Chris Webber!
Ser Charles was better
That’s ridiculous, man, Webber was bigger, he was more athletic, not even close, man
And you had nothing like Peja Stojakovic
He was no Dan Majerle
All right this guy doesn’t know what he’s talking about with Dan Majerle
Dan Majerle was trash, man
And I suppose you’re going to say the same of Steve Nash!
The Kings have never come close to talent like that
What about the White Knight of Chocolate?
Wait, wait, wait. Did you just compare Jason Williams to Steve Nash?
Have you gone mental?
Well Steve Nash never did an elbow pass
Who gives a shit?
What do you know about passing, ball hog?
All right, enough, enough!
Maybe we are a bunch of ball hogs
And maybe it is bloody hot in Phoenicia
And sure Sacramento’s...
smaller than Tucson. I don’t even know where it is to be honest
But if we put aside our differences,
and combine our houses
well then
we still probably wouldn’t make the playoffs but
Oh boy
Wh-When I look around,
I see a bunch of guys who,
I may not know their names, and
they may not be good, but they play
Basketball I think
And...
Eric…make your point
I guess my point is…
Eh…I don’t know, I don’t even wanna be here
Lord Commander
Lord Commander! Wake up!
Giannis? What are you doing here?
I have to tell you something
What is it? Did Bango fall off the ladder?
No. They’re going to exile you. At dawn
[Sighs]
I knew this day would come
Demand a trial…a trial by one-on-one!
I will be your champion!
Giannis, you’re a good kid
No, you’re a good Kidd!
It’s not right. They blame you for everything!
Eh. Well
The analytics maesters blame you for all the corner
threes we give up!
I mean, it is my defensive scheme, so
And the fanlings say it’s your fault we don’t know
when to foul in the last two minutes of battle!
Yeah, well okay, I mean, that one sort of
Even though half the knights have given up on you!
Eleven of them, actually
Here
What is it? Breakfast smoothie?
Something like that
[Coughs]
I think your strawberries went bad
Listen, Giannis
I could adjust my schemes
I could stop blaming our youth
I could even work on my time management
But I won't
Because at the end of the day
I must be true to who I am
In here
And in here
I am an asshole
I’m a stubborn asshole and I don’t have a clue what I’m doing
But...but you’re the best Lord Commander I’ve ever had
I’m the only Lord Commander you’ve ever had
Wait, did you have Larry Drew for a year? Were you...
Did you have Larry Drew for a year?
Yeah, yes, who cares?
What matters is that it’s not fair what they do to you!
[Glass breaks]
You’re giving up on us! You’re giving up on me!
Don’t cry over spilled mead, Giannis!
When life gives you spilled mead...ugh
Use it to get a free timeout…
-Ah, the Big Dog
Glenn Robinson. One of House Bucks’ finest knights
I fought beside him under House Hawks. Years ago
Lord Commander never talked about him
But sometimes I’d find him down here lighting candles and praying to the statue
Those weren’t prayers
They were curses
Ser Glenn Robinson was the first pick of his draft class
Do you know who was second?
Lord Commander?
Aye. Well, Ex-Lord Commander
He would come down here to pay his disrespects
That resentment, that anger, that was Ser Kidd’s greatest weapon
and his greatest weakness
[Sighs]
We were just getting comfortable in his scheme
Ser Ray Allen
He was pretty comfortable fighting under George Karl
They spent years on the brink of conquering the East together
But they never did
Things grew toxic
Five years later, Ray was finally a champion
under Maester Rivers
his sixth Lord Commander
His Airness, Ser Jordan was a great knight under Doug Collins
but it was under the Zen Maester that he became a champion
-Don’t forget about Steph Curry, mate!
Ah!
What the? Delly?
He was quite comfortable with Mark Jackson
but Steve Kerr really put him over the top
What are you even doing down here?
I was just down here scrapping around
Actually found a pretty cool cave. You guys wanna come check this out?
Wow. What is this place?
This must be pre-merger
Ancient House Hawks maybe?
I don't know
Is that–is that Wilt Chamberlain?
Nay. George Mikan. The first giant
What–what is this? Look at all these pale dwarves
Oh my gods, these must be the White Men of the Forest
I only heard about them in stories
They were first to play this game
Looks normal to me
Look here. No three-point line
Why is he holding the ball like that?
They were too weak to shoot overhand
Some of these guys weren’t even full-time knights
They were tooth maesters when they weren’t playing
Man, this thing must be thousands of years old
Oh look over here
This guy's holding a basket
This looks like the earliest drawing
Oh yeah, that must be Maester Naismith
Wow
Legend has it, he settled Balleros and made our holy sport
He’s the father of us all
There, yeah! Look! It says here
Thou Maker. That’s him!
Wait...wait. That’s not a...
That says Thon! Thon Maker!
Uh, Jason?
How old did you say this was again?
Oh! What happened to Lord Commander?
Are you OK?
He was attacked...at the end of the 4th quarter
by the Jester
While the Rivers boy laughed
I will break their ankles!
Nay nay
Nene’s in the other tent. Should I get him?
I mean no
Violence is not the answer
But sometimes, it is
It's futile, Chris
You know the gates of Stables Castle are impregnable
There are other ways in!
Now House Clippers share their castle with House Lakers
which means doubly fortified walls
They were reinforced to protect Kobe from Shaq after his exile
And then re-reinforced to protect Kobe from Dwight
And then re-re-reinforced to protect Kobe from trying to unretire
It won't be easy
I’ll need our best five
So that’s me, James, Clint, Trevor, Eric...
or Ryan...wait no
We need someone expendable...a journeyman
You. What’s your name?
Green, ser. Just signed a 10-day
You're in
The Stables Castle has a secret back entrance
a wheelchair ramp built for Ser Paul Pierce
Synchronize your sundials
If we time it right, we can slice through their lazy zone defense at the rear gates
Ah, a backdoor cut
Exactly
But we’ll need a distraction
That’s where you come in, Clint
[Knocking]
Who goes there?
Oh, hello!
I’m here from Big Balleros Brand
Would you be interested in purchasing some boots?
Uh...
How much for the sandals?
Uh...great choice
They're actually on sale for...
400 gold
Wait, what?
Above the back door is a small window that leads to Donald Sterling’s
secret roost where he would send his racist ravens
It’s easy to spot because all his birds were white
Hoist me up, and I’ll sneak in and unlock the door
Uh...they're autographed by Lonzo Ball
The GOAT
Wait...aren't you on House Rockets?
Um...
Cuz if you are...
Please take me with you!
Why’s he taking so long?
Do you–do you think he got caught?
Welcome to the Stables Castle
Once inside, we'll have to walk on eggshells
You see, Sterling’s Roost is now the chamber of Chuck the Condor
the most horrifying mascot in the Realm
All right now, you lead the way
Me? Why me?
Do you want a guaranteed contract?
Well, yeah, but—
Then do–then go!
[Crack]
[Terrible screaching]
Oh gods, he just ate him
He just ate that journeyman guy!
Oh no! He's coming back
[Hotdog impact]
Hunting for fowls. It's what I do
I don’t know. Are condors considered fowl—WHOA
[Hotdog impact]
And-1
We then descend past Phil Jackson’s Zen Garden
and into the shrine to Kobe built by Kobe to honor himself
Now what?
I don't know
There’s supposed to be a secret passageway
James, check his closet
Nothing...just some skeletons
Here! Look
Hm...
I bet it's–ugh!
Two!
Four!
[Mambas whipping]
Ugh!
Mambas! Black Mambas!
Trevor!
Uh okay, um, think! Think! Eight! It’s got to be eight
Wait. Hold on! Hold on!
It could be five! For each championship
No! It's...it's 81
Kobe scored 81 on Ser Jalen, the Knight of Roses
Of course!
Yes! Yes! He values individual accomplishments above all others
Eight!
One!
[Stones grinding]
[Mechanism whirring]
Trevor, are you okay?
Ugh, I’m suspended
Go on without me. Finish what we started
Better him than us, I suppose
This will take us to the locker room doors
Now in the event that we encounter the Jester,
we implement Operation Jenner
Cheers, thanks for coming out, um...
So my squire year, some of the older blokes
take me to a whorehouse…to a whorehouse...
Ugh...can’t I just cross him up or something?
James, we’ve been through this
He will whine and howl and the guards will be all over us
It’s true, no one can whine like Blake, he’s the best
Second-best. Second-best. Sorry
All right, on with the dress and off with the beard
Oh, I don't know. It's not just a beard
I am The Beard
Do it for Lord Commander
[Sighs]
Goodbye, old friend
[Cutting]
Your beard, James
And your pubes
You look…
...stunning
I just...I don’t know if I can do this
Don’t worry, James
Instead of acting like you’re getting fouled,
just act like Kendall Jenner
Uh...hey, baby
Kendall? What are you doing here?
I came here to...dunk
I–I mean talk!
But–but I’m at work
Well, you haven’t been rebound—you haven't been responding to my ravens
I don't think you sent me any ravens
I was Eurostepping—I mean I was Europe modeling!
I mean I was in Europe–I was modeling in Europe, you see
I'm an influencer model
Kendall, are you okay?
Sorry, lately I’ve been feeling a little beard
I mean I’m feeling a little weird!
I’m James Harden
I mean, I’m Kendall Kardashian–Jenner?
Ah, ref, where's the call?!
And that’s when I make...the move
What are you doing here?
Doing something I should have done a long time ago
[Slap]
Gotcha, bitch!
Daddy!
My home island grows near
When we get there my brothers will bestow on each of you great knowledge
And hopefully turn this season around
I don't see anything
Before you see them...you’ll hear them. Sh, listen
[singing]
Replay is a joke. It’s good for the officials but bad for the game
What is that? Some sort of…chant?
It’s a rant. A Van Gundian rant, Tobias. These monks have taken a vow of no silence
[singing]
Dwight Howard is always waffling and complaining. He is a coach killer
Ah, yeah, that’s lovely. I could listen to that for minutes before getting annoyed
Oh, there she is! The Isle of Van Gundy
[laughs]
Home sweet home
[singing]
And if you flop...
You should get a technical…
[singing]
foul
And if you flop…
[singing]
You should be fined millions of…
gold!
[singing]
And if you flop…
You should be suspended from the…
[singing]
game!
Because flopping ruins the game!
[singing]
But they don’t listen to us
[laughs] Brother Stan!
Brother Jeff!
Is that really you?
How the hell are ya?
Ugh, terrible! The whole foul review system’s a mess
Nobody listens to me. How are you?
I’m miserable. We’re stuck in the damn ninth seed and I’ve tried everything
Could use a bit of your help, Brother Jeff
Ah, the Van Gundian Monks will always help a coach in need
Knights of Detroit, C’mere and form a f--king wall
I want you to meet my brothers. This here, this is Jeff Van Gundy
Hello there!
That’s Ethan Van Gundy
Pleasure to meet you
Reff Van Gundy
That there is Jan Van Gundy
Greetings
I'm their second cousin
This little guy is Gundy Van Gundy
He’s severely gundied, so don’t say nothing about
“load management” in front of that one
Ah! That'll ruin the game and you know it!
All right. Ethan, can you show the knights to their chambers?
Our training begins bright and early tomorrow
If you can’t make your free throws, they’re gonna hack you all day
I don’t know, I just sorta feel like…I don’t need analytics to tell me LeBron is good
You know? I know that. I can see that
Ugh, I’m just not sure this will be enough, Brother Jeff
The Lords of Detroit will have me head if we don’t make a run in the playoffs this year
You know, there is another option. I mean, you are the Master of Trades, right?
Aye
Well, I hear whispers of a wealthy lord
who’s looking to part ways with his most decorated knight
If I send a raven now, they can be here on the morrow
Ugh...I just...
Ah, screw it. Send the raven
I think you’re gonna like him, Brother Stan. He’s even balder and louder than I
Developing! Developing! Developing players! Let’s make a trade, baby! Woooo!
Ser Blake Griffin
But he’s the face of your franchise
And soon he can be the face of yours
All right, but…who would you want for him? Tobias is a good developing player
Yes, him
All right! You’ve got yourself a dea–
Also Avery Bradley, Boban the Giant and a first-round pick
I mean...that’s quite a lot. What kind of contract do you got him under?
Five years. 171 Million
Seven hells, that’s a lot of gold
I mean,
Ser Griffin’s a marvelous talent and all
Do you know he once dunked over a horse?
Clydesdale
Ah, wow, that’s...that’s really athletic. I just...171 million gold...it’s a lot...
Oh, and did you know, he’s…funny?
Oh? Is...is he now...
Blake, tell us one of your jokes
Um...sure...yeah
Uh, so…cheers. Thanks for coming out everyone…um...
So my squire year, some of the older blokes take me to a whorehouse—
Not that one. Not that one
Right...um...so a ref walks into a bar...and then a table...and then some chairs…
[laughs]
Because he’s…because the ref is blind!
That’s great, laddie
It’s a deal!
Fare thee well, House Pistons! And remember, stay away from those analytics folks!
[chanting]
Alonzo
Mourning
What they doing?
That there is the ceremonial exodus of the Van Gundys. Watch
[chanting]
Back cut, down screen, ice, ice
Go forth to victory! And please give our tidings to the maiden Rihanna!
Bey! Ah, Bey
I...don’t think she’s a maiden
[laughs] This lad!
I've got a feeling we're going to have a long, bright future together, Blake
[crow cawing]
Ser Kristaps, are you excited about your new Lord Commander Fizdale?
Looks like House Knicks won’t be getting rooked any time soon. Huh?
[crow cawing]
Fizdale hates European big men!
Don’t listen to it
Crows are all liars
[crow cawing]
Joakim Noah has a shit contract
Well, OK, not all crows
I know a story about a bird
His name was Larry, and his hair was fair just like yours
But he had a third eye that could see into the future
Also a bad back
I hate your stories
I know a story about a child who hated stories
I also know a story about a Chris Childs who punched Kobes
I could tell you about Ser Ewing the Sweaty
Those were always your favorite
Those weren’t my favorites
I could tell you the tale of Starbury shaggin’ in his wagon with the marketing apprentice
Is this the sort of salacious and flirtatious story you like?
Uh...no?
Maybe you’d like a scary story
[scoffs] Think you can scare me, Walt...Clyde...whatever your name is?
There is nothing more frightening than being the second option to Carmelo in the triangle
Oh, my sweet Latvian child
What do you know about fear?
Fear is for the elders who’ve suffered through the entire reign of James Dolan
Fanlings are born and live and die, all without seeing a playoff win or a decent draft pick
It was in this darkness
that Isiah Thomas gave a 5-year contract to Jerome “Big Snacks” James
Who?
Exactly
That is the time for fear, my lanky lord
Watching Stephon Marbury, Steve Francis and Jamal Crawford
three shoot-first guards—try to coexist in the same backcourt
Draft picks busting in their cribs
Bloated contracts for bloated players
Women smothered their babies
rather than see them watch Eddy Curry get paid 60 million gold
to eat freakin’ lemon cakes on the bench
And don’t get me started with Bargnani!
Fear is for Lord Dolan playing lute,
and having to tell him he’s razzlin’ and dazzlin’ when inside you’re crying and dying
but you keep lying and complying because it’s terrifying and—
[knocking]
[lute strumming]
Oh...
Did I just hear...Lord...ah...Dolan roll–roll in?
Hello, yes, it is I, Lord Dolan
Just wanted to stop and sing Kristaps here a little cheer-up song
Oh, how delightful and exciteful
[clears throat]
Here we go
[lute playing]
[singing]
Better find a sept
A good place to cry
[singing]
‘Cause we’re not going to tank or play Frank Ntilikina ‘cause Mudiay’s our guy
Better find a sept
[singing]
A good place to pray for all your sins
Will I overpay Trey Burke?
[singing]
Or let him walk away like Jeremy Lin (that jerk!)
And Oakley is still not welcome back
[singing]
Maybe I’ll re-sign Jarrett Jack
Hell, I’ll pay the luxury tax
[singing]
to give Tyreke Evans a max five-year contract
Ooo!
[singing]
I should bring Isiah Thomas back,
and the small one, too, for a longer deal
[singing]
I think Elfrid Payton is the next Bradley Beal
All right, Krislaps Porzmingis
Time for you to hurry up and heal
A little birdie told me Fizdale hates his European big men
[laughs]
Talk to you later, buddy
See you in Lithuania
Where's Oakley? I want to kick him!
C’mon, Ben. Take a three-pointer
What are you afraid of?
Oh, right...the fact that it definitely won’t go in
This guy talks more trash than a young Kobe
And also takes more bad shots than the old one
At least I take shots, Benny one-point
All right, just roll
Some of us actually have real games to play
Rude
All right, I’ll fake the pass and then drive the lane
Ugh, four
Oof, that’s a turnover
Ooh, mistakes like that can cost you Squire of the Year
But I guess you can always try again next year
Whose turn is it?
I think it’s...Fultz. You’re up
No, thanks. I’m not ready
What’s happening here?
Wait, you got the new 1K?
Yeah, just came out
But, it’s the end of the season
Well, they’ve got to hand-carve all the graphics, Lonzo
How is it?
It’s pretty realistic
Except they made my hair look painted on
That’s because it does look painted on
Oh, says Mona Lisa over here
Well–can I see mine?
Sure, let me find it
Here’s Gordon Hayward
Derrick Rose
Ah, crap
Klay Thompson
Wow, graphics are uncanny
Ah, here ya go, found Lonzo
Oh thanks
I think–wait, I think that’s Michael Carter-Williams
Ugh
[laughing]
Very funny
Lonzo, your rating’s actually pretty solid
What about mine?
Um
You know
This doesn’t look anything like me
I guess they got lazy towards the back of the draft
Well, what’s my rating?
It's a 72
What? I’m a 72 and Lonzo is an 80?
Weren’t you in a bloody egg last year?
Yeah, but that was like a special magical thing
It’s probably changed, it’s just that we haven’t gotten the update raven
Why don’t you just create your own knight?
[sigh] I suppose I should
Ugh, what are those?
Those are your default 1K boots
You start with them
Nay, little me can’t be seen in these
C’mon now
You can purchase swag for your character from Ronnie 1k over there
But I’ll warn you, it gets expensive
500 coppers for boots?
That’s madness
Huh, well, you can’t put a price on style
I’m going to fancy up me character
Don’t start without me, alright?
Hey, uh...you Ronnie 1K?
That’s right, fam
I am
Well, I’d like to try out some of your haircuts please
No samples!
You try, you buy
[scoffs] C'mon
Well then, I’d like your finest fur coat for my little knight
That’ll be 100 VC
What–what's VC?
Virtual coppers
Uh, OK
Here
No, the–these are real coppers
We only take virtual coppers
Well then, how do I get virtual coppers?
You pay me real coppers
Are you–uh
Right
So, can I get 100 virtual coppers?
There you are
It’s empty
Well, that’s cause you just went and spilled ‘em all over the floor
Inbound to Lonzo
What do I do?
First, call out your move
You’re on a team with Kuz and Donovan
Markelle, you ready?
No
OK, I’ll send a full-court pass to Mitchell
Alright, roll for it
[dice on floor]
OK
Now, I’ve now picked up all 100 of my virtual coppers
off the floor
and I am handing them to you
Please give me the fur coat
[laughs]
Nice try
What?
You're three short!
So after the battle, you run into Matt Barnes
He asks you if you’d like to join him on a 95-mile quest to kick Derek Fisher’s ass
Do you say (A) Violence is never the answer or (B) But sometimes it is?
Ugh, seven hells, this is so boring
Can we skip this?
Nope, sorry
According to the rules, you can’t skip the woodcut scenes
All right
Pure sharp, Demigod, Alpha Dog with Limitless Range
Y’all are barbeque chicken
Damn, Kuz
And it only costs me 20,000 coppers and three of me goats
All right Kuz, get in
Fultz, the game is almost over
You sure you don’t want to sub in?
OK, I’m ready
Um...hesi pull-up jimbo top of the key
Oops
All right
My ball
Two points away from the win
I want to dunk over Ben Simmons
[laughs] Uh, you know I’m a wee bit taller than Kevin Hart, right?
All right, well, we’ll find out. Roll for it
Boom!
Eighteen!
I win!
Who says I’m not Squire of the Year?
Actually, no
You miss
What do–miss? How? On an 18?
Yeah, I mean your dunk rating
It says here your dunk rating’s only 50
A 50?!
You need to roll a 20 to pull off a stunt like that
Well that’s horse manure
I won the bloody dunk contest!
At least, I still haven’t received an update
Hey, Ronnie!
Fix your bloody 1K server ravens!
I’ll bet by the time that update gets here
I’ll have already have won Squire of the Year
May I just mention that I’m the third-leading scorer on the second-best house in the East
despite devastating injuries to our finest knights?
I think that deserves some consideration
Well, if either of your houses were in the West
You wouldn’t even be considered for Squire of the Year
Stop your squabbling, children
The damn Squire of the Year award is overrated
By this time next year, nobody will even remember who won
Oh, yeah? And who the hell are you?
But, why must you leave?
I’m a free agent now
Will you be back?
Aye. One way or another
But...but, where will you go?
I will raise the sails of me heart
and let the winds of destiny blow where they–
-C'mon mate
You’re wearing a Lakers tunic
Well...yeah
Paul, you realize House Lakers are bad, right?
Russ, in my years, I’ve come to accept
that I will lose in the playoffs no matter where I go
But Los Angeles has a beach
[sniffles]
Alright, well
I must be going. Grunion season is upon us
Yah yah!
Surf's up, mate
Aw, c’mon now, Russ. Don’t worry. I’m not gonna go anywhere.
[sob]
[murmur]
I actually kind of liked Pusha T’s diss track
I don’t wanna tell Drake, though
[murmur]
I thought he went too far talking about Drake’s parents and all
[bang]
Shh, shh, Drake wants to say something
You’re wondering why I brought you all here
After all, we just had a feast to celebrate our No. 1 seed
And since when does Old Drake give two feasts in a single fortnight?
[murmur]
Yeah, we love you Drake!
Well it’s no good being Lord of the Six
if you can’t celebrate a
first-round victory with your woes
The great knights of House Raptors!
Yeah!
Yeah, we're the North!
Sure, the scribes, they don’t want to talk about us
[grunts]
Some dingy house in the North
[laughs]
They all just want to talk about The Process
Boo!
Ben Simmons can suck my–
And the washed up King LeBron
Boo!
I hate LeBron!
Well I say, LeBron can have his stupid Feast of the East
Yeah!
This year, the North will feast
on the East!
[cheer]
But first, a toast!
No more of that southern horse piss
Proper wine for proper knights
Courtesy of your Champagne Papi
Stand together!
North...over everything!
North over everything!
Not you
I’m not wasting good wine on a damn horse
Here, to the men who slaughtered
the Wizards in only six games
That's right, we did!
Yeah, they suck!
Yes, yes. Cheer.
Brave men. All of you
Took six games to beat a house
that had three less wins this year than the Nuggets
That's right! Oh...
Haven’t you little northern knights learned?
After all these years,
killing pawns means nothing
if you can’t fell the King
[choking]
Am I dying?
No, we're just choking. You'll get used to it.
When people ask you what happened here, tell them King James still rules the East
Also, tell them I’m better than Michael Jordan
King James has slaughtered the Raptors in four battles
But I thought The Messiah Ujiri could walk on water
Wah! Any other Master of Trades would be torched
The King then conquered Bostonia after a grueling seven battles
Wah! Tatum’s ceiling is still lower than Fultz
Hm, what’s this?
Bryan Colangelo is dumb and his collars are too big, ugh
Wah! Brian’s collars are normal-sized, find a new slant
Aw, thank you Honest Abe
Wah! Bryan is a class act! I worked with him. So classy!
You know, when my wife decided to raise little burner ravens, I had my doubts
But I’ve really grown to love you all
Even you, little Jacob Reuben
Wah! Bryan you’re so attractive. Jahlil failed his physical, did you know that?
Oh, Phila1234567, did someone mention me?
Hmm...from Joel
Lord Hinkie is better and smarter than you, Eric Jr.
Eric Jr.?!
Wah! Wish I had a medium-sized ladder!
Shh, shh!
What’s this? The Curious Case of Bryan Long Collars?
Wah! Normal Collar!
Shut up, shut up!
It's long
Bryan, are you in there?
I’m busy!
Maester Detrick of the Ringer Guild has published a paper
accusing you of using burner ravens
Is this true?
What? No, that’s ridiculous
Sorry, Honest Abe
Wah! Class Act!
Where is he getting all this?
Some analytics wizard did an analysis of the scrolls
Analytics wizard?
No...
[gasps]
Hinkie!
[knock, knock]
That you, Lord Ainge?
[muffled] Teamwork
Gordon? Another late night of boardgaming?
Alright, Terry. I think maybe you’re taking this “scary” thing a bit too far, no?
Your Grace? What are you doing here?
Dah!
Aah!
[pant] Hwah!
It is your time
Spurs of the East
[screams in pain]